hi there my name is sue lloyd I was born
inside freak on fifteenth of july in
1997 in 2004 i moved to australia sydney
where I currently live and will probably
do so for the rest follow so just a bit
of information from me to you is that I
am a film for now I love to watch films
make him do whatever I want I'll say out
one day I aspired to be a film director
a screenwriter possibly after and my
plan B is obviously a cinematographer so
that is just a little bit about me I'll
say as a charter with had imagination to
create stories i'll use my toy figurines
and they go and play the bill to really
just exercise my that part of my brain
to creating stories and pretty much in
my room and have the time i love my wife
because it was like a like a pretty much
my own of cinema so i guess when i
started or when i found out about script
writing in that you could take that
element onto the page it wasn't before
long I was pretty much i'd be writing
little things and daily basis and being
able to exercise that part storytelling
and be able to cut it together on a page
which is which i love because at the
time i was into filmmaking in or very
similar to the process I mean that yet
to write it down and the way that i came
across at words and my friend during
history class ii he was sneaky open up
his laptop and begin writing down the
pretty much be writing a new script or
new idea and it was great because
teacher thought we were writing notes so
what do i do i just picked over and what
Twitter was writing and i was very
interested by what he was doing and ask
him where could i get this program
celtics so is obviously free and as soon
as i was able to download i was done her
girls writing down as much
actually the good but ours I was
definitely practicing the craft so that
was a back back in 2014 now it's 2016
solid two years I've been writing my
current script I started last year in
August and I pretty much wrote for two
months cutting in 2 2016 I've got 60
pages down so pretty happy as a feature
film feature length and it's called bold
and the story follows a man who has
everything he wants he's attractive he's
got the girls all it lasted for his
number he's got friends that are I guess
you could say just that the up in the
hierarchy his talent makes way for him
makes way for him so he has opportunity
to right left and south that lead to
different career parson he's pretty much
is everything is going swell until he
discovers that he is bolding it explores
how insecure men about their looks and
how society to seize bold people as
masculine or not attractiveness it's
quite interesting because I never would
have thought of doing a script about it
but you know YouTube banners give you
inspiration i was browsing on youtube
and i'll click on the add in a pop up
with video and you'd see this horrendous
butchering of the head sculpt and how
they did it was bloody and there but it
was very interesting and just led to
keep my curiosity just led to the side
to side to side of how to stop it and
the drugs they take to slow down but
what really made me you commit to the
script was I found a quote online for
the sites and it said ninety percent of
men experiences and the other ten
percent feared there's no chance i'll
stop writing the script this is
something i want to finish and hopefully
one day that i can make into a film or
feature from my goal with it is to
finish it this year I would love to
enter into a lot of script competitions
one being crowdsource to do which you
guys talk a lot about screenwriting
teacher
to structure a story how to make
something float on your paper but be
able to work on screen if you were to
make it into a film you're going to
write things that are relevant your
inspiration has to come from your own
kind of interests not others otherwise
you're writing stuff that is just being
picked over without the knowledge of how
to write a script there's no other
there's no chance of anything else being
great with that a great script I right
when I'm on the bus on the train in
general right everywhere I guess there's
never a perfect place when you've got an
idea inspired to write you just go ahead
and do it see ya my goals as for this
year is to make a short short script of
30 pages my fetus script which is bold
and what's so a TV pilot script with all
those scripts I I plan to enter them
into competitions and to really hone in
on how to tell a story so that when I
want to make it I'm fully on par with my
vision and I can create something that
is visually stunning on the page as well
as on screen
well I'm only 18 and I'm gonna be
running for two years so I haven't
really got a career such have a garden
me story can make one up a funny
coincidence that my friend and I we did
screenwriting like we just kind of
shared ideas and we'd write one script
and send to each other one day I came
with an idea and want to tell my friend
he had the exact same idea so I from
special but so far I've stool a lot to
experience and definitely those stories
that I can incorporate into my
screenwriting which is what about to do